Today. I am announcing my plans to become your next mayor of London.
Whew.
[inaudible].
Christmas came early, boys. I have been calling this for over a month. Now.
I'll show you proof right now. So you know that I'm not lying. Look at this.
This is me. The 17th of September,
Brian Rose is going into politics in the next 12 months. I'm calling it now.
I knew it. Why?
Because everyone was seeing through his lies,
his deception and people were starting to see who Brian Rose actually is.
He's a grifter, AKA. He goes back and forth between different causes.
Never really sticking with one. Just trying to get your money. Oh yeah.
And he's really good at it.
He got a million dollars for the digital freedom platform.
What has he done with that? Nothing. He said he was going to build a platform.
Instead he hired out third-party software. He said he was going to Sue YouTube.
He hasn't sued YouTube. He said he was going to get blockchain technology.
He hasn't gotten blockchain technology. Instead. He spent your money for what?
Where's those additive accounts. Oh, well, sorry. He's moving on.
He doesn't care about your money anymore that he took from you instead.
Now he's going on to his next grift. Actually,
he had a grift before running for mayor, but this is his newest grip,
which we'll get into in a second. Uh,
but I knew that he was going to do this right, because Grifters got a grift.
And when they fail to come through on their promises,
they have to move on to the next thing quickly. Right?
So he was supposed to be the freedom of speech guy.
Now he's moved on from that he's lost patients cause his followers no longer
support him. So then he moved on to this new thing.
It was a reality show that he launched in June 23 of 2020. Yeah.
And we want to help you create that.
And it's formation that didn't work. So he's got to move on to the next script.
He can't get money from you that way.
He's not getting any of your donations anymore. He's got to move on.
So now he's running for politics. All of a sudden, out of nowhere,
I see videos like this, how we get London back to work. And I say to myself, Oh,
this fits with nothing Brian has done before. It must be a campaign.
He must be running for office. And sure enough, I was right now.
Let me say right up front. Whether or not you agree with me,
whether or not you want Brian Rose to win. Let me tell you,
you tubers have a bad track record with running for office.
I'm just going to be honest. If we're talking about his legitimate odds,
regardless of my opinion, regardless of your opinion, you know, we have a low,
we don't have a huge sample set of YouTube. We really only have a few examples.
We have people like Carl Benjamin who ran for office in the UK, uh, failed.
We have people like Joey salads who ran for office in America failed.
Now you can argue case by case what mistakes they made and running.
But by and large, it seems to me that, uh, just YouTubers deciding that,
Oh yeah, I could just run for office.
I don't think they fully understand that this is not a game you can just jump
into overnight.
So my prediction is this is going to be a total disaster.
I think the media is going to eat him alive.
His supporters are going to eat him alive after they realized he doesn't
actually care about free speech. And he doesn't actually care about, uh,
censored voices.
He's going to drop them like a hot potato as soon as it's politically
convenient. And I think his history of grifting is going to eat him alive,
his history of failing to come through on his promises and his repeated lies.
I think it's going to catch up with him because he's already asking for more
donations. I mean, Brian, I bet you didn't donate. Rose is back baby.
It's your email address? And he wants your money. Third,
give us your email address below as well as a link on how to volunteer and
donate to my campaign.
There it is. All right, look at that. Look,
there's a little donate button and everything.
I wonder how he figured out how to fundraise like that. I mean, honestly, dude,
I think he's going to head fake his supporters again. He's going to be like,
yeah. Donate to my campaign. I'm Mr. Politician now. And then in three weeks,
he's going to drop out, take the money and run.
I will need the help of every citizen of this great city working together
towards our common goal.
To be completely honest with you guys. I think Brian's biggest advantage.
If I'm going to pay him a compliment is that politicians are sleazy.
They're deceptive. They lie, they cheat, they steal,
Hey then I just give the Tinder profile of Brian Rose.
So I actually think in some ways maybe Brian Rose is the most fit utuber to ever
go into office. And for that reason he could be a good fit, like in terms of,
I think he can lie enough. I think he's definitely enough of a snake.
So I think he's going to do just fine in that sense.
But I also think his ties with David, Ike,
people like that are going to hurt him.
And I think he's going to try to distance himself from those people,
but that it's not going to work.
And his followers are going to hate that because they like Brian Rose.
Cause they think, Oh man, he, he actually is one of us.
When in reality he just used David Ike for his own means.
He's going to throw them away as soon as he can. I mean,
but one thing I want to call out from the very get go is that he lies about like
why he's running for office. He says he wasn't planning to run for mayor,
but that he couldn't stand idly by.
I had no intention of becoming your next mayor.
I have always been an entrepreneur and a broadcaster first.
I've always been a grifter.
But then I realized politics is one of the greatest grifting games of mankind.
And that's why he chose to run for mayor because he's just scrambling his
businesses failing.
He needs something to do other than his business because no one believes in him
anymore. I mean, if you look at his most recent crowdfunding campaign for, uh,
you know, his followers, his grifting campaign,
he's only raised $2,500 of the $250,000 he
needs in this month. And it's already halfway through the month.
So people aren't supporting him anymore. He knows it.
He needs something to shift to, which is why he's running for office.
That's my prediction. We will be covering this. I'm fascinated, dude.
If anything else is going to be super entertaining and I'm here for it, dude.
Anyway, that's it. I got, I'll see you.
Guys next time,
but you didn't donate all the people that donated to the original freedom
platform you didn't donate.
You do shut us down near the freedom bowl. So again,
we're closing this thing out on May 3rd.
So one need your money donate to my campaign. Amino. Love your mom, man.
[inaudible] everything that you've donated. It's being put to use.
[inaudible].
Appreciate it. I'm putting it to a series of use.
Here. You might say I'm crazy,
but I say donate to my campaign. I, they didn't donate,
but they didn't donate today.
I'm announcing my plans to become your next mayor.
Let me guess you didn't donate.